genius brain listeners this podcast is
brought to you by fume cold turkey may
be great on sandwiches but there's a
better way to break your bad habits
we're not talking about some weird mind
voodo from your crazy neighbor we are
talking about our sponsor fume and they
look at the problem in a different way
not everything in a bad habit is wrong
so instead of drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad from
your habit stopping is something we all
can put off because it's hard but
switching to fume is easy enjoyable and
even fun fume has served over 150,000
customers has thousands of success
stories and there's no reason that can't
be you join fum in accelerating
Humanity's breakup from destructive
Habits by picking up the journey pack
today head to trif nume.com and use code
genus to save 10% off when you get the
journey pack today that's tr.com and use
code genus to save an additional 10% off
your order today genius brain listeners
this podcast is brought to you by
mmobile Mt Mobile's best offer of the
year is here for a limited time by any
3month planning get three more months
for free by going online and eliminating
the traditional cost of retail bmobile
passes significant savings on to you all
plan plans come with unlimited talk and
text highspeed Data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network use your own
phone with any mmobile plan and switch
easily and effortly with e Sim switch to
mintmobile and get premium wireless
service starting at just 15 bucks a
month for a limited time buy any 3month
mintmobile plan and get three more
months for free by going to
mintmobile.com genius5 that's
mintmobile.com genius5 cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month at mobile.com
genius5 uh it was like if if men and
women were given a choice if they if
they found a partner that that uh had
80% of what they wanted would you accept
that the guys of this PO this in 5 4 3 2
1 what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of The Genius brain podcast I am
your host David so still in my Hawaii
outfit because we shoot two episodes a
day and we don't ever change and we have
Emanual from dorm payment baby I haven't
changed in three days baby let's go
let's [__] go dude let me ask you
something and I always want and don't
take this the [__] wrong way okay all
right when did you start balding cuz I'm
always see this is why I want to ask you
this right okay I feel like for a guy
mhm having your hair is so [__]
important right it [__] with your
self-esteem if so I had a buddy in
college that started balding when he was
18 show it now can't hide anymore he
started balding when he was was 18 yeah
same here really uh younger 17 I was in
high school is it a family thing like a
genetic thing definitely I was lucky
enough to have my father in my life so I
knew who he was and the hair uh issue
that he shared you know what I'm saying
but uh yeah when I was when I was
younger I had a beautiful head of hair I
had waves beautiful waves [__]
reminiscing right now silky waves um and
then as I started I remember it was high
school like I was playing football
around that time and I remember just
rubbing my head and the feeling is the
first thing that you notice it feels
thin it it's not so much that you look
in the mirror you can see anything but
you kind of feel over your hand it's
like this feel why does it feel I could
feel my head but I don't see a
difference yet but I just feel it and I
just remember you know you start
brushing your hair a little more and you
start seeing follicles falling out and
uh the guy say that when I got to
college I had a full head of hair but I
really didn't I was going through that
whole issue then so I kind of It kind of
grows you up a little bit to be honest
with you you just got because it's like
it's like a slow death you know what I
mean it's like you know and I had to
choose the life that I wanted to live
because as a balding man you going to
either have the cue saac you know people
call it the cue saac the George
Jefferson the George Jefferson right and
I couldn't at 17 18 19 20 years old have
the George Jefferson that wasn't going
to happen so I made a decision I'm I'm
just going to shave my head and I'm just
going to see whatever happens happens
and uh you know my friends told me hey
you have the head for it and I didn't
you know growing up knowing that my dad
was bald knowing that Michael Jordan was
bald knowing that Tupac was bald Mike
Tyson all these there was a lot of bald
Brothers out there and that and I most
importantly I knew they got there [__]
you know I knew there were you had
Heroes to look up to yes I had Heroes to
look up to so I wasn't like oh I'm the
too nervous but it was still like damn I
don't have that thing I once had I had
to deal with something with losing
something that was a part of me that was
a you had it super young though yeah
it's not even things that you could
prepare for because as a 17year old
you're not thinking you're going to go
bald yeah no no no not not that young
you're not thinking you're going to see
the you know the beginning stages of it
and then you got years of dealing with
that okay are you going to start doing
drops or some [__] taking pills all this
[__] and I I was like I didn't want
to go through all that I I did try the
drops I tried the you do like
finasteride and minoxidil or yes one of
those and um I tried the drops for a
while I probably didn't stick to it long
enough to be honest with you I was just
like I'm not going to do so I don't want
to add something to my life yeah yeah
yeah all right it's already hard enough
to focus on brushing teeth and flossing
every single day to incorporate minox
whatever it's called into my head I was
like I'm I'm not doing all that [__]
and so I just committed I was like I'm
going to shave the head ball did that
like [__] with your like self-esteem for
a little bit or were you just kind of I
accept this [__] it cuz sometimes when I
see dudes listen one of my boys my best
friend this guy is [__] ruthless yeah
we had a buddy of mine who was going
bald and my buddy was also going bald
early huh so he decided to shape let me
tell you something if you ever wanted if
you if you ever went bald black is the
way to
be bald black people just look so if you
go bald make sure you go black that's
right you better [__] Rachel dos all
that [__]
up yep trans R you see me go bald
suddenly I get darker like yo Dam you
chill bro cuz like I feel like like you
said there's already people in the black
community who are affluent that are
powerful that are bald it already looks
good if I go bald people immediately
assume I'm a monk that's it I have no
other path I have no other [__] path
is there any famous bald Asian man who
who's the like
Gandhi that's about it that's all we got
that's it that's it nobody else gandi
there's no sexy bald Asian dude we don't
really got that like Asian people love
hair like that's like their thing yeah
that's that's that's the part that's
yeah when I when I started like losing
hair a little bit it was I started
losing hair cuz I was just [__] up my
head I didn't know I was shampoo like
twice a day and I was ripping out my
hair I didn't know that was a bad thing
and then it it started growing what age
was when was this this was like six
seven years ago okay okay and then I
started noticing my hair was super
thinning and I'm like and I've already
had very thin or fine hair so it's never
been that thick I've always had fine
hair but then I started seeing my hair
come out I'm like oh [__] I got to get
buffed
now got it I got a fight that's the only
thing I could think about I was like oh
I can't be fat anymore right right cuz
now I'm Buddha so this is like the only
like if you if as an Asian person if I
lose all my hair I have to be buffed I
have nothing else now yeah there there
is no other way around dud there's no
other way around it and then I just like
found out it was like oh you're
shampooing too much and then my hair grw
back I was like oh okay I got to just
chill off of that stuff and I always go
to my barber I'm like hey don't you
[__] you tell me the moment you see
balding you let me know so I can figure
out what to do with this [__] and and
are you guys ruthless with each other
like for for Koreans are like oh Asian
people in general are just ruthless and
like my mom too let me tell you so at
the wedding right yeah my dad calls me
up a few days before cuz he's supposed
to do a speech yeah and he calls me up
and he goes hey how much did you weigh
at your highest just out of nowhere and
I go why are you asking that he goes
just on your wedding day this is 3 days
before the wedding just let me know and
then during the wedding day he starts
doing his speech and he was like my son
I remember he got so fat he was 290 lbs
like that's why you asked you asked for
the [__] speech that's why you
[__] asked and he says this [__] in
Korean he goes I saw him walk up to me
from a distance and I thought he was a
walrus and I'm sitting here like yo what
the [__] guy give me the [__] mic and
he just roast me I told my dad something
the other or this was like a couple
months back I was I broke up with an ex
of mine so and I was telling my dad my
mom's coming into town she was flying in
town and I was telling my dad yeah we're
not together but I don't want to tell
mom until she gets here and I I'll just
break into it because they knew each
other and stuff and
um two day like like the next day before
my mom even AR arrives in town my mom
calls me she's like hey I heard you when
your girl broke up I'm like yeah I kind
of told Dad to hold off on telling you
cuz I want talk over the phone about and
he was like well he he he told me yeah
you know it's okay it's fine it's fine
and so she skipped past it but the next
day she calls back again and it's like
hey I just want to apologize I shouldn't
have told you that now your dad's mad
that I told you before I was supposed to
keep that she was like but we tell each
other everything it's and it was so
interesting to see the dynamic of like
oh yeahall like it's it's y'all are
human you're just you're just can I tell
you something parents can't keep a
secret to say they're fcking life wor
[__] let me tell you this [__] when I
was in high school right I got dumped by
my very first girlfriend and of course
as a young guy I'm crying I'm crying cuz
I just got dumped by the love of my life
right I'm in my room and then my mom
comes in and first of all this woman has
this woman is Stone Cold as [__] like
I'm translated into English she just I'm
crying I'm in my I'm on my bed sitting
at the edge of my bed I'm crawling I'm
wiping my tears my mom opens the door
she sees her son crying she sits down
next to me puts her hand over my
shoulder and she goes only little
[__] Cry by themselves in their room
and then she just gets up and she leaves
and Clos the door and I'm like what the
[__] and I'm like I get her I'm like hey
can you just not tell Dad that I got
dumped like I'm not just don't do that
she goes of course I won't [__] I
maybe 5 seconds later my dad comes in
she goes he goes you got dumped I'm like
what the [__] hold secret word sh what
the [__] and I was so [__] pissed and
she has been known to never be able to
hold Secrets there was something else
that happened it was between like me and
my brother and something happened with
my brother and I told my mom not to tell
our dad because my brother and my dad
butt heads a
lot next thing you know my brother calls
me she goes did you tell Mom and I was
like hold on one second and I call my
mom and I'm [__] heated this is this
is like two years ago and I'm like what
is wrong with you oh my why can you not
keep a promise and I literally asked her
this in Korean I was like are you going
to [__] die if you hold a secret and
she goes
yes I will die she was I can't do it
don't tell me anything I'm like dude she
had to come to Jesus yeah like I can't
hold like more women just need to admit
that because like honestly it's like
none of them can hold the secret she
cannot I've never seen my I was like
dude you lit it's like if I if I
committed a crime you would turn me in a
second you can't hold a secret at all
like I'm [__] I'm done for dude that's
who my mom is she's [__] wild dude
but like you know is she on the phone is
she like a go gossip queen like on the
phone with she doesn't she probably
doesn't really gossip like that per se
but within the family she does say stuff
to other people outside of her family
don't know [__] but then our family
knows everything right so she kind of
keeps that's her rule it's like family
can know everything everybody outside
can [__] off you know so she kind of
keeps it within that
which I understand too my rule too is
and I think that a lot of people don't
understand this it's like let's say we
got a whole group of friends right I'm
allowed to talk [__] about the person
within the friend group with the other
people within this friend group group
right anybody else says [__] about
anybody else in my friend group you get
the [__] out of here yeah that's that's
that's ultimate exent because it's like
you're bringing why why are you bringing
other people into like if if we go out
and I just hear somebody say hey I heard
you you got dumped yesterday by like why
are you how do you know that yeah like
why are you you know I heard you've been
masturbating every day like why do you
know this this was supposed to be godam
heard you still listen to R Kelly dude
yeah like right Jesus Christ yeah but
you know a lot of people don't know that
[__] Rule and I found out like moving
into the city like I don't know maybe
it's cuz I grew up in such a like
tight-knit Community everybody kind of
kept [__] here yes and so I found out
that not everybody follows those rules
and there was like a specific girl that
I used to work with and she would we
would have like ISS isues within our
group that we would solve and hash out
well during the time that we're solving
this [__] this girl was like tell
talking our personal [__] to everybody
else when it wasn't solved yet right
it's like we could solve this within
family and it's not even a big deal but
the way that she would go out and tell
other people our personal business it
would always come back to us cuz they
would be like hey like we heard I'm like
how did you hear about that right and
they would like well this is what
they're saying and I was like well did
you hear the full story and they go that
makes more sense and I'm like what are
you doing you but obviously those people
are the ones that you have to like
cut the [__] out right and let me tell
you in The Last 5 Years there's been a
lot of cutting people the [__] out dude
I mean honestly they're snitches yeah
that's kind of what it is they're
snitches they're they're they're the the
urban I mean the uh Suburban version of
snitches you know what I'm saying you
telling on your friends and like
spreading stuff around it's just like yo
that's not what a friend would do you
know keep things to your chest if I tell
you something you know in in secret a
lot of people like to do this [__] it's
like it's called like trauma bonding
where they they'll [__] oh yeah
they'll connect with somebody by talking
[__] about another person that's all
they do and then when that enemy dies
they don't have a friendship anymore
right right and they turn on each other
and you'll see that happen all the time
I [__] hate that [__] [__] n yeah
that [__] away from me and like what I
explain to People Too is like well why
is it okay for you to tell complaints
about your other friend within the group
is because we all know this [__]
right and then we could talk about it
with that person later after you hash it
out with this person to talk your
thoughts to because we know this person
that's the best way to handle [__]
you're getting advice from your friends
the people closest to you that know okay
they know this person and you so yeah
it's like hey bro it's like listen I
know my girls aren only fans but I need
you to [__] unsubscribe right right
right you know like you've been [__]
jacking off to my [__] girlfriend for
the last year and I don't like it Rome
asked me this question one time that I
think kind of relates but it's more
about family like let's say I introduce
you to a family member of
mine okay you come over one day or
something to the house and y'all end up
getting along really good with a point
where you exchange numbers and you you
start developing your own relationship
but me and you fall off
now how do you handle that do you stay
in touch with let's say this is my
brother cousin sister some something
along those lines or do you just step
away I'll give you my answer after go
ahead for me I've never had to deal with
that [__] because I'm always loyal to to
the source I'm always loyal to the
source because that's a great way to put
it I it's like that with divorces right
if I came in let's say you have a wife
right I got really close with your wife
because we started doing couple [__] and
all other stuff but then something bad
happened between you guys something sour
and y'all split I'm not her friend
anymore yeah exactly exactly you are my
acquaintance through Emanual you might
be a great person and how I look at it
like this they go why is that fair but
listen you're not going to die if I'm
not your friend yeah you're you
literally will not die right if there
was something so important to the part
where your life was wrecked then maybe
it might be a different situation right
but people are able to move on and you
don't need me in your life what we have
was great but I'm connected to this
person and my loyalty lies with the
person first yeah yeah yeah I think it
has to be like that because when it
starts being funny and because then
that's it does feel least like a
Betrayal on the other side if I'm not
talking to this person but you're a
friend of mine and you're still hanging
out with that person I don't it's a
weird thing yeah I don't even like talk
to exes or anything you yeah oh me
neither I'm I'm I move forward yeah I
don't like that whole back stepping and
like going going to talk to them it's
too complicated like I I just can't do
it cuz like I saw you naked and my dick
was in your mouth yeah I'm never going
to get that image out of my exactly it's
just all I see it's oh [__] you know you
were you were one of mine and look I
Look to each their own right you can
handle your personal relations however
you want but I'm just saying for me it's
it's just really difficult because we
connected on an emotional level in a way
that I don't with other people so what
we had was what we had and if I'm not in
your life it would make your life easier
to for me not to be there you don't have
to do all these mental gymnastics you
don't have to do any of that [__] start
your own life start if we see each other
it's cial hey what's up how you doing
shake hands move on whatever the [__]
maybe even give you the one arm hug
right here and then we just move the
[__] on the best situation could be for
that girl to possibly just move out the
city I thought you would say the best
thing for her is for her to get to a car
accident if she's dead the better all
right or like a Korean drama she just
forgets you from Amnesia right right oh
oh I have no idea who the [__] you are
but yeah I mean that yeah that's a weird
situation to have yeah but like loyalty
is very important to me right like i'
I've I've kept friendships for a very
very long time I have the same friends
that I had since I was 14 2 3 4 5 we
still talked to each other till this
[__] day half that wedding was from
friends from Sacramento and the other
half was friends that uh were from La
even though it was like a 70 person
wedding like I had to make these choices
and there were people who I've known
since I was a kid and we we're still
friends we still do very different
[__] things but one of the things
that's tried and true is that they've
always allowed me to be myself they're
always allowed to be theirselves and
even if we don't have the same career
paths we still have so many things to
talk about and there's no jealousy right
whenever I see my friend succeed I'm
like that's [__] dope yes when we
when we see this when we have this thing
where sometimes when they people see
people win and they go well how come
that's not me oh it's like you shouldn't
even be thinking that you should be
thinking damn that's [__] dope that's
a demon yo demon when that seeps into
your brain and you start that jealousy
that Envy from your to your own friends
to your own family and stuff like that
that is a demon seeping into your spirit
that you need to get the [__] out
because it's like why live like that
though yeah man I mean because it's it's
it's your own self-hate or something
you're not you're not happy where you're
at in life you're not not happy with
what's going on around you and now it's
like [__] man I don't like the person
what's the end result to that right like
does that make you feel better it
probably doesn't right you're just kind
of sitting and stewing in your own
thoughts so when you see other people
succeed and they're doing really well
you should take that either as a
motivation or happiness that your
friends are doing really well right
right because if you're sitting there
like when I see other people do really
well right I'm like oh [__] that's
[__] dope I got to get on my own [__]
too it's not a comparison game it's just
a reality check of like oh step your
[__] up right right you know and if it
doesn't happen that way it doesn't
[__] happen that way but their MO
majority of my friends are financially
way better than me yes you know what I
mean they're all way financially better
than me but it doesn't make me feel a
certain way right right definitely when
we go out to eat I don't pick up the
bill right right they damn well know
they better pick up the bill you got
millions of dollars you want me to pay
for this [__] I ain't pay for [__] you
know they know it too they don't shove
it in my face like when the bill comes
around I just go
and I slide it over like I'm the bad
[__] here you go there you go I have an
only
fan you sucking on them clams did you
see that video the girl doing a whole
she she ordered like she went on her
first date genius brain listeners this
podcast is brought to you by fume my
friends cutting a habit out cold turkey
is really really difficult but have you
heard about fume we're talking about
fume baby they look at the problem in a
different way not everything in a bad
habit is so instead of drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit you get it my
friends instead of bad fume is good it's
a habit you're free to enjoy and makes
replacing your bad habit easy fume comes
with an adjustable airflow dial and
designed with movable parts and magnets
for fidgeting giving your fingers a lot
to do uh which is helpful for
distressing and anxiety while breaking
your habit wow it's super perfectly
weighted it's extremely fun to fidget
with and guess what you're breathing in
such amazing amazing stuff like think of
of a refreshing herbal tea it's honestly
tasty I enjoy it very much I use it in
the car when I'm driving a lot so my
friend stopping is something we all put
off because it's hard but switching to
fume is easy enjoyable and even fun fum
has served over 150,000 customers and
has thousands of success stories and
there's no reason that can't be you join
fum and accelerating Humanity's breakup
from destructive happenss by picking up
the journey pack today head the tri.com
and use code genius to save 10% off when
you get the journey pack today that's
Tri fun.com and use code genius to save
an additional 10% off your order today
with a whole bunch of uh she went on a
first date the guy didn't show up yet
and she started ordering a bunch of
clams clams or yeah I think it was clams
and she's like o he didn't show up so I
started buying these clams and it's like
rose I think she ordered 45 on total it
was like God damn and the guy showed up
and he ended up just dipping on the date
like he said he was going to the
bathroom and just left yeah cuz he
thought his date was a otter and he said
I invited you for drinks yeah and you
expect me to pay for all this and she's
just like and the sound she made in the
video was just
you know what let me ask you this cuz
this has been a huge thing that I've
been seeing online a lot it's like all
these like random street interviews
where they're asking these girls what
they expect men to make or what they
should do and I almost don't know if
they're joking or not because the
expectations were ridiculous there was
this girl this Australian girl right she
might as well be very cute to each their
own right to me not so much mainly
because of her personality but she was
sitting there and she was sounded like
she was a little drunk but I wasn't sure
if she was joking or not but from the
comments it seems like like no she was
actually serious cuz she they were
asking how much should a guy make if
they want she goes
$500,000 at least right and if you can't
afford that then don't even [__] ask
and I was like is are you serious like
and what you want him to be like the top
percenter yeah what 1% and then what
makes you think that that one percenter
is going to go for you yeah this random
girl on the street screaming her [__]
H like what what are you thinking about
and then you read the comments and
people be [__] going on her dude they
were like she they need to make half a
million because she needs to eat and
they were just like [__] go God damn
[__] hurt my [__] feelings dog they
said he's going to have to buy whales to
feed this [__] but I I just feel like
you know I I've seen compilations though
yeah of just women saying these
ridiculous prices I'm like
yo am I not am I doing that bad is this
the norm for guys know is 200 he has to
make at least 300,000 500,000 a mill I'm
like 50k ring right we have to be on a
yacht we have to be I heard this one
girl say oh I want this such and such
type of ring and the uh uh the
interviewer asked her oh uh what type of
ring is that how she was like oh it's a
$250,000 ring and I'm like
$250,000 ring I mean that's crazy cuz
you as a human's not worth $250,000 what
the [__] are you talking about like what
in the world are you talking about yeah
have you seen how much slaves go
for like it is nothing it's [__] two
goats [__]
$250,000 oh my God so I don't know where
these again I feel like we're living in
the ' 80s movie this was one video that
I saw that it was really funny uh I'm
not sure if it was supposed to be funny
but I find humor and everything but she
was talking
about how much a a a guy should put down
on a first date and it she said that a
minimum of $300 or something around that
ballpark for a first [__] date are
you out where the [__] are you going
that you're spending dropping three
bills by the way on her D not on you and
her just on her I'm married I would not
spend $300 on my wife on a date there's
no [__] way we went to Disneyland
because you worked at Disneyland the
tickets were free and then I brought
food into the park are you in
yes yes yes listen no [__] way I
don't I don't know what's happened man I
mean I I remember like women when I was
younger like as a kid that women you
know family but also like outside like
friends and and and other people's
parents maybe there' be like coupon
Getters like cut up coupons and oh get a
good deal that [__] turns me on when I
see a woman doing that now hey hey if
you a lady out there you want Facebook
Marketplace what's up what you want
[__] offer up my God offer
looking for them good discounts gets
excited when she finds good discount oh
my God about to buy a plane ticket and
she goes that's full price we'll wait oh
my that's type of yeah man but now just
seeing all these videos of just I I
don't know what's going on I think it's
just Instagram and it's Instagram social
media and people seeing each other on
these girls see each other on Yachts you
deserve more yeah and it's more and more
and more it's like but y'all are getting
away from reality mhm reality is not
this living in opulence look I'll say
I'll even put it like this no matter
what a girl looks like right that is
just not happening right right and
honestly I just don't value things like
that right I value great conversation
time your mind you know like this
connection type of thing but for her
she's like so this girl this you know
this specific person was and this guy
was kind of asking her like hey why do
you feel like you're worth that much
just on a single meal right or when you
guys go out she goes well okay let's
break it down I spent $50 for my makeup
for my serum blah blah blah so I spent
about like $1,000 on my serum but he
goes who was that
for it's like and he asked well who is
that for she goes it's for me and then
he's like well then how does that equate
to what are you talk if it's for you he
goes well I look this good but it's like
at the other hand you don't think he's
trying to look good too you don't right
right he just he just left work and just
came straight here said and here the
here's the bigger question that I have
for that right too right it's like okay
if I asked you from an outside context
outside of dating I'm like why do you
put on makeup you do it for men don't
you they like how dare you yeah yeah
they they won't even say that no I do it
for myself yeah how dare you I would
never I only do it for myself but you
just told me you do it for him if you do
it for yourself I don't understand why
aren't like gay girl clubs like the
biggest thing ever like right just all
girl clubs y'all can just go look nice
for each other and you know dance per
all that [__] by yourself up there while
I get to be at home and play video games
you know what I'm saying like live the
life we want to and look I agree there
are times that we you know do ourselves
up because we want to feel good but we
feel good because other people recognize
that we look good and there's nothing
wrong with that that's okay I don't
understand why that's such a like a
vilified thing yeah but to to not admit
it just to not see like you know you ask
most guys oh you know why you get a
certain car or something like that it
probably be the [__] you know what he
end up saying but for girls it just seem
a lot of these women online especially
just seem to be like I don't know women
like for myself honestly it's you know
what I do see it rubbing off on women I
know okay I see certain behaviors that
it's like oh that's like I remember I
told uh uh one of my home girls one time
like she was you know talking about
relationship stuff and I said uh yeah
man guys don't want a lot we we really
like there was a study that came out and
said that uh uh it was like if if men
and women were given a choice if they if
they found a partner that that uh had
80% of what they wanted would you accept
that the guys of this PO this was they
said absolutely 80% holy [__] schol
that's amazing that's amazing that's a
great bit rate the women in the poll
said no they said I would be settling
for 80% for 80% my dude 80% think about
that 80% is so high that is so high 80 I
get 80% of what I want out of a human
let tell you something like that's a
that's amazing let me tell you something
my wife she definitely
settled she definitely got about I would
say she got roughly maybe 22% of what
she wanted out of a man right and then
I've been over time been able to give
her the other like 30 or 40% when I
started it was like 20% and then we I've
been mold myself and becoming a better
man you know along the way so I
definitely found a keeper but that's
unreal 80% is considered settling it's
it's considered settling so when I hear
these things I'm just like what is
happening and that's why I feel good
when I see a situation like you where
you're married you know because in a lot
in our in this industry and stuff you
don't see a lot of especially Our
Generation okay the younger guys that
came off of the internet and stuff to
have a marriage to to start having kids
and family it's like a lot of us are
stuck in a situation where it seems like
uh you can't grow up for for some people
you know what I'm saying next year me
and my lady that's it's going to be our
10th year together man and time goes by
fast congratulations right and with her
too it's like I've never when I met her
I wasn't planning to settle down but I
really do feel like listen when God
gives you opportunities you just take it
right and when I met her she had
something about her I don't know exactly
what the [__] it was but I just thought
that I could spend the rest of my life
with her and I Pur and something
happened I'm not saying that Within
These 10 years we didn't have massive
fights we didn't have massive
differences and I've even talked about
this before we actually got engaged I
basically almost left her cuz we just
weren't working out right and but and
look it's not to say that marriages are
always going to be fighting and all the
time but because of these like fights
that we had and we be able to fix these
problems that we had with each other we
became better for it a lot of the times
I feel like a lot of people expect
instant gratuity all the time it's like
you know you know the mother and father
that you had that you grew up in the
household you don't think that they
fought for what they had and then you
look at them and you go they have the
perfect relationship well guess what
that [__] took time it wasn't like that
when they were younger you you guys
forget like your your parents were once
young in love teens young 20s 30s or
whatever they were [__] they were
[__] your dad was shoving that oh my
God so far up that that hole that brown
hole you know what me your mom has only
fans and you just didn't know about it
right but like you know for
us she never expected me to be at 100%
at everything that you want and I always
say this too when whenever you anybody
wants like a solid relationship by the
way when I say solid I'm not talking
about externally solid we're not talking
about the Smiths right we're talking
about what goes on in the household
there you need to have these things I
call pillars I don't know if anybody
else has the stuff too right the pillars
are the the the strong Foundation that
keeps the building up as long as those
things don't move everything else
doesn't [__] matter we'll figure it
out gotcha right is a spec specificity
family
religion F my thing is like family uh
religion communication and then trust
those are the four things right don't
lie to me right communicate how you feel
family is always important and that's
family including close friends right I
consider close friends family as well
too and then religiously we have to be
on the same thing right so I mean just
because like it's just everything and
then number five make me a sandwich
[__] I'm actually the one making
sandwiches in the house go you could go
either way I am never eating anything
she makes that girl can't cook to save
her [__] life Jesus Christ yeah but
everything else doesn't matter in the
sense that those things can be addressed
and those things can be fixed along the
way as long as I have these core things
to me that's the 100% right what
everybody else considers like when they
oh has to be handsome and needs all this
other [__] you be so surprised how much
you don't give a [__] about that [__]
when you're in year three year four 5 6
7 eight with the relationship not to
saying that putting your effort trying
looking your best doesn't [__] matter
but in the list of things that are
important those things go down because
people are forgetting there is a
categorical way to develop a
relationship it's actually a a
psychology thing you're confusing lust
and love those are two different things
you can lust after a lot of things you
could even lust after inanimate objects
if you wanted to right but love is a
very very different thing and it takes
time to develop that [__] it's almost
like this person becomes a part of you
that you literally can leave and so when
I decide to marry my wife was like Hey I
actually feel like you and I are one
yeah you know how you feel hurts me not
not to make it Island boyish but do you
feel like you become brother and sister
in a way does that does is it is that
too weird no no no no I see what you're
saying I'd say like it's it's pretty
much along the lines of we have a EB and
flow now right right there's unsaid
communication when you get to that level
of your relationship that's when shit's
the best okay you don't need to ask
somebody to fill in the holes that need
to be filled I'm not talking about
[__] I'm talking about just like the
stuff that you suck at you know they
still not talking about [__] yeah
we're
still yeah I'm talking about her sucking
my dick no um like if I'm inadequate at
the stuff she doesn't need to tell me
I'm inadequate at
she fulfills this role that she knows
that I cannot do without asking it of me
and not making me feel like I'm not
inferior exactly so she knows I can't
organize things so when we go on trips
she scheduled things out that's her
[__] priority I make sure she doesn't
get kidnapped in right right I cover the
cost I book the hotels you know what I'm
saying and I make sure that things
aren't stressful for I pick up the bags
I do all like this manual labor type of
stuff has there ever been in a part of
your relationship where it felt like um
maybe she's taking over I apologize my
no it's okay that happens I thought it
was mine yeah no it's mine but uh where
it feels like maybe she's taking a role
she doesn't need to be or you're taking
a role you don't need to be yeah for
sure is that where that's where we have
arguments right so for example like I
just told you this so my wife sprained
her ankle um uh this morning and then
sometimes you know I'm a dumbass so I
see her she's hobbling and she's on the
floor and then you know I had this thing
when I'm fixated on something that I
want to do I it has to get done or it
[__] eats me up inside and the whole
day I wanted to go into the hot tub you
know and so I see her she's hobbled on
the floor and the first thing I say to
her I was like how bad is it and she
goes she goes well I'm on the floor I
was like so are you still going to be
there if I'm at the hot tub for 20
minutes oh my God let me tell you
something it was a cold ass
night that [__] was a cold ass night oh
my God I felt the breeze in the room and
all the windows were closed bro [__] was
a rough [__] night and I just sat
there I was like and she just goes she
just looks at me she goes you're useless
and I sat there I was like damn I'm kind
of useless why did I do that cuz I just
had to go to the hot but then I kind of
mitigated everything else cuz I
literally put her on my back I carried
her up the stairs this morning I made
her breakfast I got her her drinks I got
her her snacks I asked her if she needed
something I usually do a fivemile walk I
canceled that I came over to check on
her before the podcast and then she felt
loved but that's like the thing too is
like also knowing when you [__] up and
then not trying to fight to win an
argument right right right that's like
young people early [__] where you're
just only trying to be right yeah right
[__] being right the objective of this
is for you guys both to be happy genius
brain listeners give yourself the gift
of insane savings this holiday season
with mint Mobile's best wireless deal of
the year right now when you switch to
mintmobile and buy a 3month plan you'll
get another 3 months for free that's 6
months of Premium wireless service for
the price of three mintmobile lets you
order and activate from home while
saving tons on phone plans starting at
just $15 a month seriously I can't think
of a better gift than turning an
overpriced Wireless bill into just $15 a
month with mint mobile with all those
savings my friends man you know the
economy be crazy lately so guess what
you can buy with all that extra money
that you saved a cup of coffee here and
there a meal here and there some lunch
some dinner impress your lady with the
savings that you got and and let me tell
you something my lady loves savings when
I tell her I save some money ooh that
guys are all hot and bothered so what
are you doing your L staying cold you
need to save with mint mobile for a
limited time buy any 3-month mttmobile
plan and get three more months free by
going to mintmobile.com genius5 that's
mintmobile.com genius5 cut your wireless
bill to just 15 bucks a month at mint
bubble.com
genius5 right so what are you trying to
accomplish and like I always and by the
way I'm not saying I do this all the
time a lot of the times we're trying to
be right but then in the fight we
realize oh we're both un happy what can
we do next time to make sure this
doesn't happen it will happen again but
the fights get shorter and shorter now
right right because you have a
understanding now before when we would
fight about the stuff it would be a
two-hour conversation now it's 5 minutes
right she looks at me and she goes
you're [__]
useless right pretty useless
huh yeah yeah yeah I'm like though man I
I I hope you know one day have that
chemistry to and I know it takes work
with the person you know it takes
to get to that point it's almost like
it's almost like two algorithms trying
to work together to and you got to
figure out that coding you know what I
mean like you you know when know standup
Comics they go up and they talk about
the difference between men and women I
understand now they we're so different
we're so [__] different and somehow
God just made us this way and I get mad
at him sometimes I'm like what's up man
why you do this why you why you do that
bro why is it like this cuz you choose
the other rib I know maybe the left rib
or the right rib you made the wrong
choice I know God doesn't make mistakes
but maybe this time you did but we you
know like getting to know her over the
you know past years like she also got to
know me like we grew up so differently
you know I grew up in Sacramento
California in a not nice neighborhood I
did a lot of bad things as a young
person you know selling drugs to small
children and for her she grew up in a
very protected Community okay and one of
the fights that we got into was like how
I would express my anger and how we
would Express anger in my household was
chaotic busting [__] breaking down doors
[__] screaming at each other you know
what I mean she didn't grow up with that
and I don't know if other people feel
this way in their relationship too they
go well if things went bad between you
what makes it hard for you to divorce
her it's like probably for me the most
difficult thing is not the fact that I'm
going to be a divorce is the fact that
there are so many good things about me
as a human now that happened because of
her and I give her credit for that so
it's to walk away from this because we
had an argument or we disagreed with
something would kind of erase all the
great things that happened because I've
been with her so the amount that she's
improved my life is here the fights that
we have is here so what am I going to
take I'm going to take the 80 and not
the 20 yes you know so when they say
well 80 and 20 is not good enough I'm
like you're going to be alone for the
rest of your life rest of your life and
just be happy that way yes but don't say
that you want to be in a relationship
because if you expect Perfection out of
somebody else you better expect
Perfection out of yourself right right
right and that's the part that bothers
me about that statement are you 100 are
you that person's 100 cuz if you think
that you are you're not nobody to not
have the the the the wisdom or just just
the common sense to know nobody's 100
yeah nobody's 100 every single human
being on Earth is going to come with a
flaw hey young people think about this
too right the the hundred that you see
in the person that you want now do you
think that's going to be the same 20
years from now right if you're hundred
within this category is this person's
fine as [__] guess what in 10 years
they're going to get old things are
going to Sag things are going to droop
in fact as you get older they might not
even be as smart as they were before
something might happen they might might
have cancer they might get sick are you
going to throw this person away because
they are not that H that you expected
them to be how disgusting is that [__]
you do not want a relationship you want
an object in your life that you get to
parade around like they're a [__]
piece of jewelry get a dog get a [__]
dog get a dog do what they you know put
[__] fluff them up get the pale pink
and [__] like that do all that [__] if
you want all right do that too all
whatever [__] it you know that's the
relationship you want we're there now
all right just do it episode of Black
Mirror we're here baby we're here yeah
you know what's so funny D I had this
conversation the other day with with a
homie of mine and then he noticed this
thing about me he goes hey man you don't
you don't say the nword anymore right
because in Sacramento people still say
it yeah he goes why'd you stop saying I
was like Hey listen I miss
it I was like every day I miss it there
are certain situations where that word
fits like a [__] puzzle pie right and
I'm not allowed to say it anymore and it
kills me
you have no idea it's such a it's it is
a one of the greatest filler words of
all time um people don't if they didn't
grow up with it I feel a lot I hear a
lot of people use it because they want
to use it it's like you're not using it
right though you know what I mean yeah
yeah you can hear it doesn't flow off
the T when you when you see a dude out
in the middle of the street right and
you see him acting like a fool right and
you just say this and then it fills this
Gap and there's no other word that will
fulfill what you meant at the time yeah
you're not thinking around
guy this man is crazy he's I was like
yeah I miss it a [__] lot dog I was
like but times have changed that is
hilarious that is hilar he was like N
word he was like he was like you just
never say it anymore I was like listen
it slips out because you know you've
been saying since you were a little kid
you know what I'm saying and when you're
this is what I feel about black people
y'all are so good at allowing people to
come into the community and then you
just don't know that you're in it until
you're in it in it you know what I'm
saying my biggest thing handed a a plate
of food yeah you had a plate of food or
what I went to I went to college and
then moving outside of Sacramento and I
was like oh [__] it's different out here
people feel a certain way and that's
when the words started disappearing cuz
like what am I going to argue here you
know I mean there's no point in arguing
this you just got to let it go it is
what it is what is the filler word of
everybody
else I know Mexican people is Foo that's
like their period what up hey fo yeah
that's definitely one it's just like
there do you have it in your language no
do there's nothing in your language you
guys say to each other this no we got
none of that [__] but Asian people love
Black Culture though yeah so like for
yeah we [__] love Black Culture look
at all of our music look at the way we
dress everything we love Black Culture
so it's like I like I remember the first
time where like it slipped out it was at
a at a standup comedy show mhm oh [__]
and then you know at the time it was
still somewhat acceptable not really and
the whole crowd went [__] silent what
what year is this about this was like
how old I was like
22 okay so that was like what that was
13 years ago okay yeah so around that
time yeah around that time or some [__]
like that uh we were I said it in the
set and it slipped out and the whole
crowd went silent lucky one of my comic
buddies were out there and black dude he
was like he's good save the whole set
everybody started laughing beautiful and
then it kind of rolled out good good but
that's when I realize oh this shit's
dead for me like it's just not going to
happen cuz even when people to stand up
now back in the day like I could say it
and then it made sense within the
context right so it just like that was
like the huge departure was it a part of
the joke or was it like just as a
throwaway statement it was a throwaway
thing okay it kind of came out casually
cuz cuz I feel like if you're anything
else it would have to be a part of the
joke now kind of yeah I guess so but
it's hard like Louis
CK yeah probably has the one of the most
funniest [__] jokes I've ever heard you
know what I'm saying but it was really
good it just really well done so I feel
like if if it's in that context maybe
you can get away with it but today I
don't know if you can get yeah I just
don't even want to play with that might
as well I'm not promoting other people
say it but you know I'm just comans well
I jumped ahead of this because everybody
was on that can cancel culture tip right
and especially during BLM time and I I
like BR I said that [__] majority of my
[__] life right if you go back in
time enough you're going to hear it
right but I'm not going to away from it
whatever was then is different from what
it is now and that's all that you have
to know right and a lot of people from
the outside looking in they would have a
problem with it from the people who on
the inside they never did they're just
like oh you used to say it it is what it
is everybody did and then we just moved
on right right right you know what I'm
saying and look I'm not saying every now
and then I don't say it
now all right sometimes soon as I walked
in here I what
up oh man that's hilarious it's just one
of the most you guys have to understand
during during that time of the late 90s
early 2000s it was just it was the
descriptor for joy happiness stupidity
and like there are times where I'm just
like God God you made me the wrong race
why' you have me grow up in a black
neighborhood [__] oh man when you start
calling your your kids that then then we
might revisit like you guys didn't grow
up where I did so you not allowed for
this type of [__] you little [__]
it's so funny like it's so weird when
some when another friend points it out
you don't say it anymore right and I'm
like yeah just why right right right
there's no point what am I fighting for
here do they still say it well he's
black he can say he wants you know what
I mean that's funny yeah he just the one
that noticed it the most like oh what
the [__] is there any other culture that
has a word that we would think is cool
to take like that I don't think so man
like I I feel like there no other like I
I feel like black people are the best at
it's like the whole thing of turning uh
lemons into lemonade yeah you know what
I'm saying like you gotta even think
about it from like a I love food like
culinary aspect right the [__] is
barbecue that's all slave [__] yes
absolutely absolutely you took all these
[__] meats that nobody [__] wanted
you smoke it for a long time and it
becomes delicious yeah even the idea is
of chitlins as much as I I don't [__]
with it but I understand like where it
came from what they did with it slang
pop culture all this type of [__]
everything was considered what if you if
you spoke this way listen to this type
of music you were a lower class person
right everybody listens to Hip Hop now
yeah and it's just that thing and it's
become much worse I'm be honest is it
better now I don't know I don't know if
that's bad everybody in everybody's
making it it's just like uh the problem
is you let too many people in right
there was no regulation you know what
I'm saying I'll say kick some of these
[__] out God damn it
yeah there was like this other side too
like I remember like now kids on Tik Tok
are complaining like young black kids
where if they don't listen to hip-hop or
they oh you're not black and they're
like who the [__] are you to tell me who
I'm if I'm black or not you know what I
mean it's like it's it's not a monolith
we have all these like different
cultures like just cuz I don't say this
word or I don't listen to this music
when I walk out this door I'm still a
[__] black kid the [__] are you
talking about it's just weird the
internet has made things so [__]
weird so strange man we need the aliens
to come oh I'm pretty sure they're
already looking at us just waiting for
us to get destroyed yeah either the way
to destroy to destroy us or to they're
going to laugh at us some something's
going to happen 100% man but yeah I just
like it's just one of those weird things
where I I remember just jumping ahead of
it just cuz like ain't nobody canceling
me I grew up in South sacr smart man
everybody said that [__] I already told
you go back far enough it's in there you
know what I mean connected to it you'll
find it it is what it is yeah man and
and that's good I I I I really
appreciate when people just keep their
history real especially if you grown and
Chang you know this just a part of the
story know what I'm saying so keep that
out there it's funny to I you know
what's so funny like years ago it was
like 6 six or seven years ago
now next to my parents so we own a black
beauty supply store that's why I use the
word so much and I went to a black
church so it's like it's just integrated
there's a store my whole life I thought
the store was called pun Jabs it's just
called liquor
store and I remember I went back to my
parent store and you know the people on
the block are like you about to by pun
Jabs I'm like yeah of course and I was
like went by I was like what's up and
the guy even calls the store pun Jabs
but that's only because everybody else
was calling him a pun jab so we walk in
and I remember it was like six seven
years ago I'm visiting my parents I stop
I look at the store sign I'm like it
doesn't say pun
Jabs I've been calling this place pun ja
since I was a kid yeah and it's just
called liquor store that's crazy yeah
and I didn't [__] know and I remember
I asked the I was like you like being
called pun jab he's like whatever he
doesn't give a [__] there's a generation
people they don't care they're like it's
nobody's saying anything bad about me it
is what it is there's this person in my
parents store till this day call my mom
Mrs Kim her name's not Mrs Kim dog that
is fantastic she goes hey Mama Kim and
I'm like whatever you know she ain't
trying to be rude yeah yeah why why even
change it she's been calling my mom you
know Mrs Kim Mama Kim for [__] 20
years that is hilarious yeah and I
appreciate that though I appreci cuz who
gives a [__] [__] cares she comes in we
smile we hug we see each other I've
known her since I was a little kid it's
what good person you're good person hey
those little things don't matter I did
tell her that her name isn't Mrs Kim her
name is Sayang and it blew her mind it
did she was shook she said what wait
your name's not Kim oh my she goes why
you let me call you Kim this whole time
and she was like
whatever she I'm sorry I was like you
don't need to apologize I'm just saying
that's just is what it is is like next
time she come in hey Miss Kim she still
does it doesn't [__] matter and I'm
not going to change that out of a
70-year-old woman right right right you
know what I mean course she's 70 years
old she's been coming to my parents
store for [__] since I was a little
kid yeah it is what it is like I don't
some people need to learn to be a little
more forgiving of stupid [__] you know
what I'm saying yeah and like why ruin
the community and the relationship over
something this small it wasn't racial it
wasn't anything else at the time times
were different and it was probably e my
mom couldn't speak English so she just
told her hey whatever Kim and then she
was like hi Mrs Kim and then we just
left it at that right right you know
what I mean so she as long as you're
getting treated well I was baby Kim
right I'm baby Kim she like damn baby
Kim you got big that could have gone
wrong Little Kim different different
very different Little Kim those are your
people that's not my
yeah well guys that wraps up this
episode of The Genius brain podcast I
had a whole bunch of topics I threw that
all out doesn't [__] matter we have
great conversation it doesn't matter um
genius brain every Sundays at 12:00 p.m.
check out secret society s c RT s o c i
t
y.com a lot of the stuff has been sold
out but the stuff that's still there go
ahead and cop that jumi matcha if you
want it in your store I think we're
total next year we might even have 13
stores so if you guys want it in your
city franchise we're we're we're a
franchise but you know we keep it small
and in the family and everybody has been
super successful who have opened the
store so if you want to be a part of
that family let us know and then you
could check out uh comedy Trap House
comedy Trap House dorm tment sketch if
you want to check that out and uh yeah
your personal plug though Emanuel
Richards find me anywhere uh on uh
Fridays at 7 on Comedy trap house I have
a show called Mayhem hour check check
that out we talk about conspiracies and
all the wild [__] some of these uh girls
talking about they want a $700,000 man I
still don't understand that [__] yeah
all that so yeah thanks but uh genius B
every Sunday's at 12 p.m. we'll see
you'all next time peace